je suis aux robes et bellegarde du
cameroun entrepreneur dans le domaine de
l'éducation de technologie
[Musique]
et
c'est un peu mon à perdre un besoin qui
est née juste à la suite de la crise la
pandémie de covit qui conte les écoles
sont fermées les élèves se sont vus
obligés de faire des cours en ligne mais
le cameroun et d'autres pays africains
qu'ils n'étaient pas prêts à
nouvelles technologies ont exposé des
enfants les enfants sont nous exposer
mais sans aucune mesure de sécurité le
nôtre start up les encadrent déjà dans
la maîtrise des nouvelles technologies
c'est la cyber sécurité en fait partie
les enfants se connecte en ligne ils ont
la possibilité de fait les cui des tests
de connaissance assez simple ils ont
également la possibilité de télécharger
des cours en ligne et des activités en
sous forme de quizz de questionnaires de
jeux qui peuvent télécharger et
faisceaux à l'école soit à la maison
avec des parents
[Musique]
mais le but c'est de pouvoir auprès
cette plateforme à d'autres pays pas
seulement en afrique parce que c'est un
programme mondial et il ya beaucoup
d'écoles qui n'intègre pas encore
enseignements de la cyber sécurité
numérique c'est l'identité en une fois
qu'on est en ligne on s'expose ça veut
dire que si un enfant de 12 ans
aujourd'hui commence à faire des vidéos
tik tok qui sont inappropriées ils
s'exposent est derrière son équipe et
harceleurs on est les prédateurs qui
utilisent jusqu'à moi ces enfants à
d'autres fins donc il est important de
leur dire de faire attention et surtout
de leur donner les bonnes pratiques
[Musique]